whatever you did yeah whatever you
I mean Nations closed Oh Jack I see you
were yeah Jack Bob if you may fire a
missile into that crowd of cop cars I'm
gonna come by em oh my Mike jet gave out
and I crash I'm sorry oh yeah I couldn't
I couldn't pull up an exam come back as
a [ __ ] ammunation is closed you had
ammunation jack it was I'm leavin to the
other one cuz that was closed
Oh everyone's already kept shooting us
I uh I won the best Nick yeah J yeah
Jack oh my god Mont Bob Bob everybody
yeah named Bob one of us I said yeah
I'll sue I am approximately all right
isn't there another place to get like a
tank or something there's another way
you can't get other tanks some place you
can get a police chopper I think from
like a police station or something but I
have no idea how that was to get a tank
from that place we were going if you're
unbelievably lucky and then you have to
fight your way out which is really
[ __ ] hard you can't get out with them
you could you could probably fight out
like the front gate they don't even know
the guts and unlock the gates are locked
um-hmm that's stupid
he's stupid I don't like it all right
I'm gonna come hang out with you guys at
the ammunation now that I'm just a
normal foot person again I'm not the
ammunition I got no money
I was a happy sky person can I give you
money I might be able to give you money
I got actually f3h anger I've got money
in the bank I've got money bank money
but I don't know how to get things honey
I think you can just spend it mark if
you have deposited money you can spend
that what no one told me that laughing
back the ball oh I thought you tried to
buy something and you couldn't and you
just didn't have money if you have money
in your account you can spend it you got
like a deficit or some it didn't let me
let you
me shimmery imagination now I can kill
all you [ __ ] no don't like it all
right
kill you first oh god oh god no god no
okay
oh no oh god wait ah okay
this game is very quiet no I'm
concentrating
I need a motorcycle video game actually
I have a better idea I needed one of
these I need a water DS give me this
okay okay oh wait are you squatting
right now how do i how do i move a jet
how do i do how do i do I'm in a jet Oh
W is throttle and the number pad are
like you're up and down like five should
be pull up eight should be nose-down
that sort of thing oh I'm up I'm up in
the air I'm in the air I'm a jet so
quick money there cuz you [ __ ]
weren't getting in my way you [ __ ]
Oh God okay oh you didn't tell me how to
do I don't know the keyboard controls me
I tried to plan on keyboard for like
five minutes and I was like woah no I
was doing really good I had it until I
want it and then they fired a missile at
me so that kind of the missile does make
it harder you're right I did it all down
well I did have to like turn in a
direction but then I get like turn I
couldn't turn those weird oh you need to
control her up I don't have a controller
always about some tartar of the
unbelievable [ __ ] out of us yeah I
wouldn't have known either son I lost
I'm also in the hillside in the middle
of nowhere where there's no cars and
nothing yeah you don't hear to be by the
military base in informal no exactly by
the military base but I can't I'm like
on the other side of the fence and I
can't have a car in them there's no
roads and really low everybody know I'm
really scared and it's like on a narrow
hillside where it just drops off in the
ocean I really don't see oh you're on
the wrong side dude yeah I just find
here cuz my jet blew up in the middle of
nowhere I get it now I'm not coming over
there oh look wholesome Jack might come
save you wait oh god he won't other
color buddy you're not gonna know how to
shoot
hahaha wait why don't you go save mark
no Oh Dominic I called the cab but I
have no idea where a cab yeah yeah I
know I'm on top of the wait Jack why I
kept coming back to the jacket Aires
okay I'm coming I'm coming
hey joy oh [ __ ]
okay choo holy [ __ ] there's a tank Oh
what's the Chuck man 1 oh good wait
where did you ask these guys to their
rocket oh yes I got into was like 5
tanks around there's so many 1000 God
dang it oh you're like eggs
oh wait got his fine oh thank God for
that we have the cover of wall saving
nothing
alright to cover a fog that will
definitely make it easier to wheels okay
I've actually found a good strategy Jack
so who's here wait don't leave yet
alright no wait no no no I got in a jet
I was in a jet it made it super easy to
get into jet as it led all the other
people in a circle so get in the base
and I'll tell you how to get there from
there oh [ __ ] whoa way to go that's our
that's a quick two stars
yeah wait why did that happen know a guy
just like slammed into me and it was
like ha stars [ __ ]
sounds like an encounter at a gay bar Oh
ah dick no Jack no Jack no shag Oh what
are the explosions in Wireless near me
no they're not explosions Jack Soloff
freaking idiot they're just fun drive
for [ __ ] what's good Jack what Jack Jack
who time bears you know how to drift
drifting you ready for this Blaine our
up a mess around
I [ __ ] up hang on we're not very good
we're not I thought we weren't we
weren't gonna have enough speed to make
it down there hang on I got a director
his car sucks
Jack Jack you're so dead detect act act
act act act act act act XP fish meats
maids Mandy okay go left god oh go left
go straight straight straight
alright go go go go oh god go this road
Wow all right make a right make a right
right right right oh [ __ ] okay Wow if I
could hear anything other than Jack I
think what's happening right now but
anyway straight straight straight off it
reset and lead him away oh yeah make it
right here good way around okay go
straight alright great get him back or
get him wait God have to kill that guy
you might have to gargle straight all
the way straight go no dude to the left
left left
oh well they're there their main douches
over there so we're gonna go from forgit
go for that J go for that dead that's
yet dungeon do it wait okay yeah go for
it go go Jack
me yeah go all right guys all right oh
go go go there's a shooting man come
they're gonna try to kill thank you
if I could get in the car oh no no no
come on yeah oh god this car sucks
hahaha okay I'm getting him away I'm
leading him away go dad go told you Jack
told you Jack I'm sorry
thank you Mark
you're welcome I love you I'm gonna die
now at the jet oh I have no traction oh
[ __ ] here they come
I'm [ __ ] dead oh no Kelly hey with
that am i making donuts uh it just kept
thanks Mikey you really kept him off my
back while I was getting this set you're
the bathroom hukum I helped both of you
yeah you're the best Oh stomach oh my
god
holy [ __ ] wha yeah this isn't like drunk
in there plane
I'm not drunk my innocence joins the
whip through material CAD yeah Ojeda how
because he's Irish doesn't a Bagram you
Jack I hear you been you're not gonna
kill [ __ ] I do I'm coming I'm coming
Wow damn it what are you doin engine is
dying whoa whoa whoa whoa for some
reason there's a tank out here on the
main road Oh what the hell's goin on
here
I can take it that's good I don't know
it's just us it's us out here on the
road I mean it's putting yours Oh Nevada
choppers in one not a goddamn Oh No ooh
wait awkward why don't you have a car it
flipped upside down shut up uh-huh I get
him today so tense
oh are you god it's like a war in the
skies it's insane I know I'm trying to
take out all these [ __ ] helicopters
so they start on it I'm trying to sneak
up oh why why dink does it take right
here oh it's right here boys are at
angry there it's after you [ __ ]
look what's getting away get away ow
whoo I got a police car hey ruin oh my
god my plane is dying I need an adult my
blind is dying
Oh God dude you question to me I crushed
into you know that only guy I know I
have sex
oh yeah they do that douche Oh God
okay I'm coming for landing no it
disappeared on the horizon cuz I was on
foot and I didn't have a car it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay my jet I did my
car flip upside down right outside the
tank when there was a [ __ ] tank
right Oh Cheers Oh Oh take a biggie
you ain't got that tank stop that time
whatever you do just stop that tank I'm
going actually a tank whatever you did
yeah whatever you did he kill you didn't
take just ran over him guys look is the
tank still happening is they're yellow
tactical happening Oh detect where it is
how do we stop it
you don't tanks ups you yeah I got I got
I got I got I got get out of here mine
come in and those in god damn a killem
get that tank come a-knockin the cake
I'll get into the tank
if we look I don't know maybe we can
only assume so
Oh oh my god hey wait wait the tank I'm
in the tank
he'll let you follow you [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] oh sorry
why wait I was right there really on the
dankey way kick just get to a safe place
and I were coming can I kill wait wait
wait wait wait okay a safe place same
place same place wait save the owl truck
wait wait wait wait
I have YouTube me to death you blah City
to rule 3